I just want that kind of love Suki I
just want that kind of love yeah now
that she's split from Cody Brown sister
wife star Christine Brown reveals what
she's looking for in love and her answer
it'll surprise you everything is a lot
more simple than it used to be during
Sunday's one-on-one special Christine
and her friend slash former sister wife
Janelle open up about the newly single
mother's type I think she wants someone
who really just cherishes her she has
this uh Fantasy character like it's a
statue she has in her house and in fact
he's some character from a a video game
that they made into a movie durotan is
an orc and that's really what I'm
attracted to yeah durotan like the
durotan from the World of Warcraft
Universe the first time you meet him
well he's a warrior but he's looking at
his wife with so much love and so much
and he would do anything for her and I
just want that kind of love Suki I just
want that kind of love yeah what is it
you're looking for in a new partner real
just kindness and romantic relationship
for sure someone who's attracted to me
would be a really great thing okay so
Christine might not have a romantic
future with a fictional character but
there is one real life person that's
just her type Criminal Mind star Shemar
Moore ah baby girl you never disappoint
thank you and that's beautiful
just someone who treats women well you
know Christine announced that she was
leaving Cody after 25 years of marriage
in November their messy breakup played
out on season 17 of Sister Wives you
never tried to have really good
relationship with these other people
and that's the reason I'm pissed off
that's not true and it's just I did man
just the knife in the kidneys over all
these years back in October Christine
told E.T that while she's currently
single she has been dating I'm dating
just for fun you know that just keeping
everything super light because that's
just who I am right now earlier this
month Janelle confirmed that she and
Cody are separated as well after almost
30 years of marriage
Janelle has made it pretty clear to me
that she's
enjoying her life without me I think if
we both really sat down we'd look at
each other and say really we've been
separated for several months it's easy
to start pointing the other ugly fingers
to blame yeah and so no I don't just
blame myself
but I do believe that as we go through
struggles there's always plenty of blame
to spread around and Mary Cody's first
wife called out the polygamist in part
one of the one-on-one special and
revealed they've also officially split
he's like like we're not married we're
not acting as married and I said to him
then if that's where we are don't you
think that we should address that
publicly and he said no I don't want to
address it
I don't want to dress it I don't want
that to be out there publicly Mary and I
are in an amiable relationship but we've
been like literally separated for I
would say four or five years in the
one-on-one special Robin who is still
with Cody opens up about her strained
relationship with her former Sister
Wives I jokingly refer to myself as
Cody's Whipping Boy
um when he does something they don't
like I get blamed yeah I'm an easy
target because I have a tendency to just
take it and you know just not get jerky
about it I don't fight it's not my it's
not my nature to fight the Sister Wives
one-on-one special will Air part three
on January 8th
[Music]
thank you